The joe rogan experience.
It's very bad.
While we've been going on a Paul Ryan has announced that he's going to not seek
reelection.
Oh,
thank God.
Well,
he's retired.
Paul Ryan's probably sees the writing on the wall.
What does that guy do currently?
He had some kind of realistic challenger,
a Democrat that has been really ramping up their campaign and he does not want
to stick around to see how that's going to go.
Really does want to lose.
He doesn't want to get humiliated.
You know why?
That's what it is.
He think or maybe he's just tired.
Illusion.
No Way.
Maybe needs to get paid for all those fucking bribes.
Like now it's time
saw the day that the former speaker John Banger,
I say it now on the board of a mate,
major marijuana.
He went all pro legalization.
Shit.
Got To get that.
How do you feel about this legalization situation?
I hate it.
To lock people up.
Locked up.
They're getting high.
Lock him up,
but compared to prop two 15 compared to [inaudible] 17 to 18 what do you think
what in California about it?
Well,
the 30% sales tax,
which was inevitable,
but this is what I like about that.
It's still reasonable.
You can get high on a very small amount of money for a long period of time.
That's true.
I don't think we should be calling and complaining about that too.
I think we could show that there's a real benefit to legalization that benefits
communities,
benefit schools,
firemen,
police officer's,
whoever can get that money and I think that's where the money should be
allocated and I think you could get billions of dollars for the state just doing
that and I think that is a real positive aspect of legalization.
That might be the one thing that's going to be the straw that breaks the camel's
back across the country.
When people realize that you can make real money and that real money can be
beneficial to things that communities need,
plus you starve out illegal drug selling illegal drug sellings what the real
problem is always been when you make something illegal,
only criminals are going to sell it.
Then you have criminal mentality.
You have people that have guns and gangs and those are the people that were
scared of not businesses.
Yeah.
If we were scared of businesses,
we'd be trying to close liquor stores.
Nobody gives a shit about wineries.
You know we're not.
Those are drug stores.
A winery is a drug dealer.
They are they listening to you talking about about wine?
Yeah.
Just sell delicious trucks.
Yeah,
I mean,
and I'm for,
I'm 100% I love wine.
That's not my point.
My point is selling Dwan things should be legal.
Things should be legal.
And when marijuana is legal,
tax the fucking shit out of it and give that money back to the community.
And everybody benefits people like you and I who are responsible,
grown adults prepare taxes and are good people and we'd like to get high
occasionally the,
we should be able to buy it with no worry about being locked in a fucking cage.
And that money should go to schools.
That money should go to fix the streets.
That money should go to cops and firemen.
That's what it should go to that.
And then we know where it's being allocated.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
No idea.
I would hope it's,
here it goes.
I'm joining the Board of Anchorage Holdings.
[inaudible] holdings acreage.
Sorry.
Because my thinking on cannabis has evolved.
That's my man got hi.
Yeah,
I was,
I was anti and then I got some of this good shit right here.
I'm convinced d scheduling the drug is needed so that we do research,
help our veterans and reverse the opioid epidemic ravaging our communities.
Yes,
I agree man.
I would add to that,
get high,
say wait so we can get hot.
Put everyone out of jail.
Is there,
is there evidence showing a weed reduces opioid use?
It is,
right.
Um,
well,
it really depends upon how it's used.
It can benefit some people with some kind of pain.
I don't think it's realistic to say that some people that are in horrible,
horrible pain would get the same reaction for,
I wanted to get for opiates.
People with like really bad burns,
for instance.
Are there 24,
seven addicted,
not for not medical reasons.
I'm talking about if you're become addicted to Ope,
uh,
you know,
oxies there's better drugs.
Yeah.
There's better drugs to get you off it.
Okay.